ya hemos dicho que si tenemos un campo
vectorial digamos de con dos componentes
digamos vehículo verdad podemos calcular
fácilmente su divergencia verdad la
divergencia de nuestro campo vectorial
ve y por supuesto esto va evaluado en el
punto x de verdad esto se calcula
simplemente como la derivada parcial de
p con respecto de x más la derivada
parcial de q de q de la segunda
componente con respecto de ye verdad
pero digamos nosotros podríamos dar otra
anotación que es muy útil para recordar
esta fórmula y esencialmente es poner
esto como un producto punto consideramos
aquí nuestro operador nav la verdad del
que ya hemos hablado de él cuando
hablamos del gradiente de un campo
escalar verdad y hacemos el producto
punto con nuestro campo vectorial b y
como lo hicimos justamente en el tema
del gradiente la idea de este
triangulito volteado verdad
la idea de este triangulito volteado es
digamos escribir uno
vamos a escribir un vector que tenga
puros operadores diferenciales es decir
tiene como primera componente la
derivada con respecto de x verdad y como
segunda componente la derivada parcial
con respecto de sí verdad y esta es la
idea de escribirlo como una especie de
digamos de vector verdad y por supuesto
esto no es un vector pero al menos ayuda
simbólicamente a calcular la divergencia
entonces nosotros hacemos el producto
punto con el vector o el o más bien con
el campo vectorial b verdad que eso es
digamos aquí tendríamos su primera
componente px y luego tendríamos la
segunda componente que es
muy bien entonces la idea de multiplicar
digamos un vector de operadores con un
vector que tiene a estas dos digamos a
estos componentes es no no es como una
multiplicación sino estaríamos pensando
en que estas derivadas parciales se
aplican a esto verdad entonces digamos
la idea del producto verdad sería
reescribir esto como la derivada parcial
respecto de x y multiplicamos a de
verdad que recordemos no es multiplicar
como digamos como tradicionalmente lo
conocemos sino que estamos evaluando la
derivada parcial respecto de x de
nuestra función p y luego sumamos verdad
como es el producto punto la derivada
parcial con respecto de iu y ahora
aplicada a nuestra componente q verdad y
entonces como podemos ver obtuvimos la
misma fórmula que ya habíamos digamos
construido en vídeos anteriores verdad y
por supuesto que ésta esta idea del
producto punto se puede utilizar en más
dimensiones por ejemplo
veamos qué pasaría si tuviéramos un
campo vectorial digamos digamos que
tuviéramos un campo vectorial b pero que
ahora dependiera de tres variables
verdad y por supuesto para que sea un
campo vectorial esto tendría que tener
tres componentes de salida verdad
digamos p de x y z la segunda componente
sería q de x y z y finalmente tendremos
una componente r de x 10 z verdad
entonces aquí tendríamos un campo
vectorial en tres dimensiones y si ahora
nosotros pensamos en la divergencia de
este campo vectorial verdad de este
campo victorino no es erres b entonces
podríamos utilizar la misma idea verdad
tendríamos que poner nuestro vector que
tiene digamos las derivadas parciales
son operadores diferenciales tendremos
la derivada parcial respecto de x la
derivada parcial respecto de iu y la
derivada parcial con respecto de zeta y
el orden en el que escribimos estas
parciales es exactamente el mismo orden
que digamos que aparece en nuestro campo
vectorial verdad y luego hacemos el
producto punto con el campo vectorial b2
vamos a poner un poquito más derechito
verdad nuestro campo vectorial b tiene
componentes p q y r y esto es por
supuesto dependen de nuestras variables
x y y ceta verdad entonces si nosotros
hacemos este producto punto verdad
podríamos pensar en la derivada parcial
con respecto de x de p verdad sería este
digamos como esta especie de producto
la derivada parcial con respecto de y de
la segunda componente que en este caso
sería q
y la derivada parcial con respecto de z
de la tercera componente que en este
caso sería r verdad y aunque no hemos
hablado del todo de campos vectoriales
en tres dimensiones verdad este último
término lo podríamos entender o
interpretar justamente de forma similar
como interpretamos los dos suman dos
anteriores verdad en realidad estamos
pensando en cambios en nuestra
componente z verdad la tercera
componente ahí justamente pensamos
cuando nos movemos hacia arriba o hacia
abajo es decir en la dirección de z y de
hecho este patrón sirve en cualquier
dimensión digamos no sé de dimensión 100
510.000 y esto es lo que hace que esta
anotación sea genial verdad nos da una
forma compacta para escribir la fórmula
que tiene un simple patrón pero que
quizás podría ser muy largo de escribir
bueno nos vemos en el próximo vídeo